my name is Manu Prakash and I'm a
faculty in the Department of
bioengineering at Stanford University so
I'm a physicist by training and much of
my lab focuses on two very broad themes
one half of my lab focuses on physical
biology asking biological questions with
the context and insights from physics
and the other half of the lab is focused
on what I call frugal science which is
the idea of development and deployment
of tools and technologies to make the
experience of science more available to
a broader group of people I grew up in
India and one of the earliest things and
memories that I have is just wandering
around and being outdoors exploring the
environment that I was in I remember we
had moved into the small house and the
tenant before who was living there could
not pay his bill so he was kicked out
but he was a chemistry teacher and the
landlord instead of taking money
essentially took over his little lab in
the basement in a garage me and my
brother I think we had this very strange
walking into this wonderland we
absolutely had no idea of what it was
and I even remember some of those
chemicals there was nitric acids there
was hydrochloric acid and for the next
three or four years we actually spent a
significant portion of our time in that
lab but that was the very first what I
would call my experience of science and
later on I think teachers came along who
tried to discipline some of the
explorations we were thinking about but
in the end it really started at home I
remember you know in an exam we were
supposed to know everything about
microscopy and even draw microscopes but
I'd never actually seen a microscope
although we were supposed to label all
the parts on this
so at some point of time I decided to
make my very first microscope this was
you know maybe I was 1012 years old and
the first microscope was actually built
out of cardboard boxes and cardboard
tubes you know science is in the act of
doing something so you know whether it's
pencil or paper or sitting on a
microscope or on a sailboat in the ocean
exploring life-forms that nobody might
have actually seen before to me the act
of science is really the true
inspiration most often I find myself
wandering around but even some very
simple tools and over and over again
I've realized there is so much more that
we still don't know and I think that
that really drives me and ironically
when I was taught in schools I didn't
have that feeling only after becoming a
scientist did I realize that there is so
much more we don't know so that's quite
exciting and it's a fun time to be a
scientist
you